[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE LEOTSAKOS: I
think opera resonates
with every part
of me, and I think
it's just an art form
that embodies everything.
(SINGING) My dearest child.
(SPEAKING) It's both like
drama, but not a straight play.
It has the music element.
It has the most
difficult music, I think,
and performance rigor
that's necessary.
And voices are so unique.
And to be able to carry without
a microphone over an orchestra
or just perform in that
way is just absolutely
stunning and magnificent to me.
It almost seems like a
miracle that that's possible.
And so I just think so much can
be said and done and absorbed
through opera.